Irak 2003 documentaire tiré de la série
les mensonges de l'histoire et réalisé
par Setti Dali ou comment des mois
durant Georges W chez les faucons de son
administration on cherchait à convaincre
leurs alliés que Saddam Hussein détenait
des armes de destruction massive une
manipulation de haut vol qui permet aux
États-Unis de prendre la tête d'une
coalition militaire qui décréta la
guerre en Irak une guerre à laquelle
refusera de prendre par la France et qui
plongea pour longtemps ce pays dans le
chaos c'était il y a 20 ans et pour en
reparler aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débat doc un grand témoin de l'histoire
Dominique de Villepin bienvenue à vous
vous êtes on va le rappeler tout de même
ancien Premier ministre de Jacques
Chirac c'était entre mai 2005 et mai
2007 et durant cette fameuse crise
irakienne vous avez donc été celui qui
en votre qualité à l'époque de ministre
des Affaires étrangères porte à la voix
de la France aux côtés du chef de l'État
pour dire non à cette guerre on va
revenir assez longuement sur ce qui ont
été les dates clés de cette crise et
qu'on a bien revu avec ce documentaire
première question néanmoins à quel
moment Jacques Chirac ou vous-même
avez-vous pris conscience que les
États-Unis voulaient de cette guerre en
Irak
la conviction est venue très tôt puisque
dès l'été 2002
la montée en puissance
américaine a commencé à se faire jour
avec une surprise puisque les choses ont
commencé par s'inverser par aller dans
le bon sens avec la déclaration faite en
septembre à l'ONU par
Georges Bush acceptant le principe
d'avancer dans la voie au nusienne à
travers le travail d'une résolution là
qui sera finalement la résolution 4141
donc au départ une inquiétude très forte
délétée puisque nous savions la
préoccupation irakienne pour
l'administration bouge très ancienne le
film le montre très bien dès 1998 et en
particulier après le 11 septembre donc
réactivé
le sentiment donc d'une montée en
puissance et puis finalement un
changement de pied dans la mairie qui
accepte d'avancer dans la voie
multilatérale le nutanée par
l'administration bouche donc là il y a
un espoir cet espoir il avance avec des
difficultés puisque c'est une résolution
qui demandera à plus de deux mois de
négociation extrêmement
âpres et en particulier entre la France
et les Nations Unies nous sommes leader
dans la négociation sur cette résolution
et puis au tournant de l'année alors
même que les résolutions que les que les
Nations Unies que les inspecteurs sur le
terrain commencent à travailler ils sont
sur place ils commencent à travailler
l'Irak contrairement à beaucoup
d'attentes les lettres travaillaient et
puis là on sent que les réticences
américaines continuent à se multiplier
dès le début de l'année nouvelle montée
en puissance de nouvelles mobilisations
de personnels de navire d'avion qui se
multiplient et le tournant se fait tout
début janvier et là nous avons vraiment
clairement conscience que il s'agit de
d'une voix de non-retours nous sommes au
point de bascule quand d'un côté Jacques
Chirac envoie son principal conseiller
sont concis diplomatiques Maurice gourde
montagne et notre ambassadeur à
Washington rencontrer kandiras qui à
l'époque conseiller national pour la
sécurité
à la maison et donc qui se rend compte
et là ils ont clairement le sentiment
que la décision de l'Amérique est prise
et de la même façon je rencontre à New
York en tête-à-tête le 19 janvier Colin
Powell qui a cette formule qui a la fin
de l'entretien me disant Dominique ne
sous-estimait pas la détermination
américaine et là clairement c'est un
message c'est un message que la
détermination américaine est plus forte
que tout et la réunion du 20 janvier que
nous avions sollicitée nous sommes
présidents je préside le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies à ce
moment-là c'est une réunion que nous
avions délibérément voulu organiser sur
le terrorisme notre ambition c'est de
ramener les après le 11 septembre marqué
au fer rouge par ce drame de les ramener
à ce qui doit être à mon sens la
préoccupation première de la communauté
internationale lutter contre le
terrorisme donc on veut les ramener à ça
eux hésitent ils ont peur que cette
réunion de dérive vers une mise en cause
de leur politique vis-à-vis de l'Irak et
là les choses s'accélèrent et ne
cesseront de s'accélérer de réunion du
Conseil de sécurité en réunion conseils
de sécurité mais le 20 janvier alors
même que tout semble décider il manque
aux États-Unis la clé la clé essentielle
pour partir à la guerre c'est la
légitimité et cette légitimité nous
Français nous avons la conviction qu'il
ne faut pas la donner sans raison aux
États-Unis et qu'elle doit se mériter et
le prix à payer pour la légitimité c'est
les Nations Unies c'est faire sauter le
verrou des Nations Unies et prouver que
cette guerre allez bien nécessaire et
donc que les Irakiens disposent d'armes
de destruction massive sachant que à
cette époque là rien aucun élément ne
venait prouver l'existence de ces armes
de destruction massive et c'est là où en
quelque sorte et le film le montre
admirablement l'Amérique qui a commencé
à monter en gamme vis-à-vis de l'Irak
sur un mensonge ne cesse de devoir
multiplier ces mensonges jusqu'à accuser
Saddam Hussein d'être mêlée avec
Al-Qaïda au terrorisme international ce
qui était sans aucun fondement donc le
mensonge doit grossir pour essayer
d'arracher cette légitimité en
l'occurrence principalement contre la
France qui mène le combat aux Nations
Unies cette crise irakienne vous
a-t-elle offert des moments que vous
pourriez qualifier de privilégier
avec Jacques Chirac et si oui à quel
propos à quel moment précisément de
cette crise un moment privilégié avec
Jacques Chirac
les mamans sont évidemment nombreux
sachant que je connais Jacques Chirac et
je travaille avec Jacques Chirac sur
l'international pour le conseiller en
matière diplomatique depuis 1980 donc
vous voyez c'est pas récent et que j'ai
été pendant 7 ans sont bras droit comme
secrétaire général de l'Elysée au milieu
de le préciser en vous présentant et à
effectivement et à ce titre nous avons
vécu ensemble deux moments fondateurs
pour la compréhension de cette crise le
premier c'est les attentats de 1995 et
en particulier les attentats de
Saint-Michel j'ai accompagné Jacques
Chirac sur place je lui ai appris
l'attentat j'ai vu comment il avait
réagi et et je connaissais sa
détermination à lutter contre le
terrorisme c'est la première étape et la
deuxième étape c'est le 11 septembre
Jacques Chirac est au Space à Rennes et
je lui apprends en direct
l'attentat qui vient de frapper le Wall
Trade Center et les quatre avions qui
ciblaient les États-Unis à ce moment-là
et je lui conseille de rentrer
immédiatement sans même attendre et
prononcer son discours et donc Jacques
Chirac rentre à Paris et il est il faut
le rappeler pour comprendre cette crise
puisque nous avons été accusés bien sûr
Jacques Chirac et moi-même d'abord
d'être en tri américain dans cette crise
Jacques Chirac a été comme président
français le principal soutien des
États-Unis dans cette crise dans ce
drame du 11 septembre il est le premier
à New York allez à New York et à marquer
la solidarité et y compris face à
l'Afghanistan quand il s'agira de se
mobiliser pour pourchasser ceux qui ont
commis cette attentat donc oui une
extraordinaire proximité c'est ce qui
explique madame mination comme ministre
des Affaires étrangères et
beaucoup de débats de réflexion sur
la meilleure façon de faire comprendre
aux États-Unis et au monde la position
française cette position elle part d'une
double conviction chez Jacques Chirac la
première c'est que on n'avance pas sans
raison au Moyen-Orient dans un
territoire qui rejette toute présence
étrangère n'oublions pas on avait vécu
les difficultés de la première guerre du
Golfe on avait vécu les retombées de la
guerre d'Afghanistan de l'engagement
russe en Afghanistan et on connaissait à
travers la multiplication des attentats
terroristes dans la période précédente
attentat à la Mecque attentat anérobie
et en Tanzanie attentat contre l'USSO le
dans l'année 2000 on avait vu monter ce
rejet des États-Unis et de l'Occident et
donc nous savions à quel point il
fallait agir avec prudence dans cette
région et puis Jacques Chirac est un
homme petriculture l'Irak la Mésopotamie
l'épopée de Gilgamesh Babylone on ne
peut pas traiter l'Irak comme n'importe
quel état c'est un état qui a une
mémoire une région qui a une mémoire et
donc il fallait l'approcher avec
délicatesse donc il avait le sens du
devoir et du tragique de l'histoire
dites-vous à propos de Jacques Chirac au
moment de cette crise
d'abord
il avait l'expérience de la guerre et il
est le dernier chef d'État français et
l'un des rares chefs détox occidental à
l'époque qui a connu la guerre il a
connu la guerre d'Algérie avec ses
horreurs et ces moments extrêmement
forts sur le plan humain et il sait de
quoi il parle et combien de fois je l'ai
vu face à George Bush lui expliquer
justement la fragilité du Moyen-Orient
la complexité du Moyen-Orient à quel
point vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de ces
étages l'ai entendu sur le Liban la
politique syrienne sur l'Irak pour
essayer de convaincre son interlocuteur
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une région
communaute qu'on ne pouvait pas faire
n'importe quoi et le deuxième élément
c'est que Chirac est un homme de culture
est un homme d'histoire il se rappelait
la campagne de Russie la campagne
d'Espagne de Napoléon la guerre du
Vietnam l'Algérie qu'il avait vécu en
direct et tout ça nous instruisait de la
difficulté d'intervention militaire
dans des états et des sociétés qui très
rapidement sont susceptibles de rejeter
cette intervention intérieure et cette
occupation donc il y avait en quelque
sorte le sentiment
de prévoir à l'avance qui allait se
passer on nous a beaucoup accusés dans
cette époque de d'être catastrophiste
d'imaginer le pire mais j'allais dire
pour quelqu'un qui regardait avec
longue durée
cet été on va voir un premier extrait du
documentaire si vous voulez bien nous
sommes le 5 février 2002 au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies c'est Colin
Powell qui prend la parole
tous les ingrédients du mensonge sont là
on y retrouve les tubes d'aluminium sans
ces fabriquer des bons atomes
des schémas de laboratoire nucléaire
inventé de toutes pièces
des photos d'usine chimique qui ne sont
en réalité que des stations météo alors
vous êtes revenu sur la chronologie de
ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies au sein même
de ce fameux Conseil de sécurité nous la
France est un membre permanent à un
droit de veto qui l'entend faire jouer
dans cette affaire vous nous l'avez
expliqué tout à l'heure
en réalité ce jour-là Colin Powell et
les États-Unis jouent un peu leur va
tout devant ce fameux Conseil de
sécurité en livrant le dossier des
preuves dites accablantes entre
guillemets bien sûr pour l'Irak Colin
Powell va jusqu'à me rendir une une
fiole d'entraxe dans cet extrait et
devant ce fameux Conseil de sécurité que
l'Irak est censé produire en très grande
quantité
quel souvenir personnel on vous voit sur
ces images au même titre d'ailleurs que
vos homologues européens Jack Straw pour
les Britanniques jusqu'à Fisher pour les
Allemands gorille vanhoffre bien sûr
côté russe quel souvenir personnel
avez-vous gardé de cette prestation de
Colin Powell
un agacement
croissant et en même temps un sentiment
de
compassion pour Colin Powell sentiment
d'agacement parce que plus les images
des filets plus que les poil parlait
plus il donnait la preuve de l'absence
de preuve voyez bien que ces images
ne disaient rien des hangars des
entrepôts et à partir de là des
suppositions des écoutes qui elles-mêmes
étaient coupées de toute réalité le chef
de cabinet le témoignage du chef de
cabinet est sans doute pour moi ce qu'il
y a plus fort dans le reportage qui a
été fait parce que ce sentiment de
vacuité qu'il exprime c'est exactement
ce que j'ai ressenti moi lors de cette
séance il y a là un dossier vide et un
dossier vide qui ne vaut que par la
double signature attendez il y a un
dossier vide parmi les éléments que
monde Colin Powell à l'occasion de
cette intervention devant le Conseil de
sécurité
aviez-vous des éléments dont vous aviez
déjà pris connaissances dont les
services français d'enseignement avait
pris connaissance le Quai d'Orsay ou pas
alors il y a plusieurs éléments dont
nous avions pris connaissance en
particulier
la question des tubes d'aluminium les
fameux tubes d'aluminium d'aluminium
était posé et on avait beau tourner ça
dans tous les sens ça ne fabriquait pas
un réacteur nucléaire on ne conduisait
pas la fabrication des réacteurs
nucléaires
l'élaboratoires mobiles tout ça ne
donnait aucun élément au service de
renseignement vous l'avez assuré
absolument les services de renseignement
là-dessus sans pouvoir donner une preuve
absolue parce que nous sommes forcément
dans un domaine où on est obligé de
faire des suppositions mais à aucun
moment ce que les Américains appellent
le smokingen le pistolet fumant c'est à
dire la preuve établie mettait à portée
par les Américains et ce qui nous a
fasciné passionné c'est que plus le
temps passait plus on sentait qu'ils
étaient obligés de rajouter des preuves
qui tout était plus fragile les unes que
les autres et c'est ce qu'on avec
l'uranium du Niger l’uranium du Niger
quand les Américains mettent sur la
table le fait qu'il y aurait eu un
contrat entre l'Irak et le Niger 500 kg
absolument tout cela apparaît de plus en
plus comme la preuve de l'absence de
preuve de la même façon les Britanniques
nous environ un certain nombre de
d'espions du maïx pour nous briefer sur
un document confidentiel qu'il voulait
rendre public ce document confidentiel
quand ils nous l'ont expliqué je me
rappelle encore revoyant ces autorités
britanniques
truffée d'âneries c'est-à-dire que nous
étions devant une évidence du mensonge
et et donc je vous le disais lors de
cette réunion d'épreuves un agacement
formidable et en même temps Colin Powell
que je connaissais depuis longtemps
j'avais déjà fait la connaissance de
Colin Powell quand j'étais en poste aux
États-Unis j'ai été 6 ans en poste aux
États-Unis de 84 à 89 alors chef de
France en charge du Moyen-Orient et donc
suivant directement ces questions
j'avais déjà été observateur de
mensonges d'une précédente
administration qui était la ministration
Reagan dans le dossier de l'Iran contras
ou absolument les Américains avaient
cherché à vendre des armes à l'Iran et
en échange financé des opérations de
contraste au Nicaragua donc il y avait
des familiarités avec des choses connues
il y avait Colin Powell qui est un homme
pour lequel j'ai une profonde estime je
crois quelqu'un d'une grande humanité
d'une grande expérience et dans cette
sur le plan strictement personnel et
humain j'observe que cet homme
est en grande détresse il exprime une
très grande fragilité il y a une image
qui le montre le visage et est en
mouvement permanent le visage est bourré
d'inquiétude cette image de tenette d'un
côté le patron de la CIA et négro-ponté
leur présentant Nations Unies qui sont
là comme deux gardes du corps pour
l'épauler et le tenir c'est c'est toute
cette détresse qui s'exprime d'une
administration américaine et d'un
secrétaire d'État américain qui fait
naufrage et le même jour le même jour à
déjeuner nous nous retrouvons avec tout
le Conseil de sécurité Coffe et
qui est meurtri de la prestation qui a
eu lieu j'ai eu l'occasion dès la sortie
de la réunion du Conseil de sécurité de
m'exprimer devant les médias avec une
agressivité vous l'imaginez ces médias
vis-à-vis notamment du représentants
français immense et de dire à quel point
je ne croyais pas un traîtrement de ce
qui nous avait été présenté et donc on
se retrouve à ce déjeuner tous ensemble
et Colin Powell a besoin de se justifier
et il se justifie en disant à quel point
cette guerre sera rapide et mettra très
vite fin à la vie du dictateur qui
maltrait de son peuple ce sur quoi nous
étions parfaitement d'accord il
s'agissait pas de contester le moins du
monde le caractère dictatorial du régime
de Saddam Hussein et il prend un exemple
il dit
cette guerre se réglera rapidement comme
nous avons réglé en c'était dans les à
la fin des années 80 la guerre du Panama
qu'il avait lui-même dirigé et j'ai pris
la parole pour lui dire bien sûr Coline
vous avez fait un très bon travail au
Panama mais l'Irak c'est pas le Panama
et ça ça marquait bien le à quel point
pour les Américains la méconnaissance et
du terrain et la méconnaissance des
conséquences de la guerre et quelques
instants plus tard l'après-midi je
retrouverai en tête-à-tête Colin Powell
dans un moment qui est un moment
peut-être les plus vibrants de ma vie
diplomatique puisque quand je rentre
dans le bureau de Colin Powell où il me
reçoit la science unie en sort le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
bulgares qui me regardent
pas dans les yeux et de façon très
dépité en me disant j'ai pas le choix
Dominique et je comprends que j'ai pas
le choix que d'accompagner les
Américains dans leur vote au Conseil de
sécurité donc je comprends que la
Bulgarie va suivre les Américains je
rentre dans le bureau de colis Powell la
première chose que je lui dis c'est
Coline il y a des pratiques que je
considère comme un qualifiable nous
sommes dans un moment que nous couvre
pas bien sûr le reportage puisqu'il
n'est pas centré là-dessus qui est les
pressions faites par l'administration
américaine sur les états du Conseil de
sécurité pour les forcer à aller au vote
et nous menons nous le combat inverse
et là je dis à quand une poêle je ne
peux pas accepter que l'on cherche à
faire chanter certains états et là Colin
Powell se dresse sur la table me regarde
et j'ai vu le moment où il allait me
donner un coup de poing j'ai vu cet
homme blessé mais en même temps je
voulais lui faire toucher du doigt que
le mensonge des États-Unis allait nous
entraîner dans quelque chose de
totalement illégitime et cette ce moment
fait que les choses basculent puisqu'à
partir de là Colin Powell sera dépassé
et débordé par le reste de
l'administration Dick channel
Candy rise et bien d'autres et il finira
le par le pays de sa place d'ailleurs il
le paiera de sa place bien évidemment
quelle chance d'informations aviez-vous
au niveau européen c'est une question
qu'on a envie de se poser notamment avec
les Britanniques qui suivront évidemment
les États-Unis dans cette affaire les
Britanniques à l'époque c'est Tony Blair
qui est le premier ministre britannique
quelle était la tonalité de vos échange
avec votre homologue britannique Jack
Straw par exemple sur cette crise
irakienne on a un peu étonné de voir
après coup à quel point les Britanniques
ce sont laissés en brigader y compris
les renseignements briques à vous le
disiez à l'instant
pas étonné pour plusieurs raisons mais
la principale c'est les liens
extrêmement étroits entre la diplomatie
britannique on en est toujours là au
Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis les
Britanniques ce sont d'emblées affichées
dans cette affaire comme les meilleurs
élèves de la classe Atlantique et à ce
titre ils étaient en appui de George
Bush on a beaucoup spéculé sur la nature
de leur relation y compris de leur
relation sur le plan religieux avec un
George bus ayant un très fort ascendant
sur Tony Blair mais il faut rappeler que
les Britanniques n'étaient pas seuls il
y avait un autre monde du Conseil des
sécurités à ce moment-là et non
permanent mais membre malgré tout qui
est à l'Espagne et il y avait l'appui du
Portugal
Barroso et il y avait l'appui de
Berlusconi l'italien donc il y avait
beaucoup d'États européens j'allais dire
la majorité des grands États de l'Europe
de l'Ouest et puis tous les états de
l'Est et les pays baltes la fameuse
lettre adressée par les pays de l'Europe
de l'Est en soutien à l'administration
britannique à l'administration
américaine montrait bien que de ce point
de vue là nous étions relativement
isolés et c'est là où avec Jacques
Chirac on a eu l'idée d'essayer de
s'appuyer sur quelques étapes dont à
l'époque bien sûr l'Allemagne et
certains on met la rue que Chirac aurait
pu être influencé par le fait pacifisme
allemand aussi à l'époque avec
évidemment celui que lequel il
s'entendait très bien spoiler et jusqu'à
Fisher qui était votre homologue du côté
de s'attarder là-dessus parce qu'en fait
la position française
n'était pas seulement ou pas tant dicté
les relations avec les États-Unis ça
c'était un aspect des choses qu'il
fallait bien sûr prendre en compte mais
la plupart des observateurs et ou des
acteurs français ne voulaient voir qu'à
travers cette relation entre la France
et les États-Unis et je me rappelle le
Medef les intellectuels français venir
me voir pour me dire à quel point nous
allions gâcher la relation
franco-américaine que nous proions
responsabilité historique l'obsession
française
les conversations que nous avions avec
Jacques Chirac tournait autour de trois
objectifs le premier objectif c'était de
défendre la légitimité internationale et
donc la légitimité des des Nations Unies
l'idée qu'il y avait en débat
l'affrontement entre le multilatéralisme
et l'unilatéralisme le deuxième cheval
de bataille c'était de défendre l'unité
internationale nous avions fait voter la
résolution 1441 à l'unanimité des états
y compris la Syrie dans un moment qui
était après le 11 septembre et donc il
était essentiel pour l'efficacité de la
communauté internationale au début du
siècle de mettre tout le monde dans la
même barque et la troisième combat
c'était le combat pour l'efficacité nous
savions que la guerre pouvait avoir
l'air d'un raccourci mais qu'elle ne
mènerait rien au contraire qu'elle
allait creuser le fossé entre le Nord et
le Sud creuser le fossé au Moyen-Orient
nourrir le terrorisme et notre souhait
c'était de bâtir un modèle multilatéral
en matière de lutte contre la
prolifération qui puisse servir dans
d'autres crises au même moment nous
vivions la crise en Corée du Nord et
donc si nous arrivions à bâtir un modèle
commun d'inspection et bien ce modèle
pourrait resservir pour la communauté
internationale deuxième extrait du
documentaire c'est votre propre
intervention au sein du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies et c'est un
vieux pays
la France d'un vieux continent comme le
mien l'Europe qui vous le dit
aujourd'hui
Dominique de Villepin rétorque
sa position est inflexible l'usage de la
force ne se justifie pas aujourd'hui
il y a une alternative à la guerre
des armées l'Irak par les inspections
alors là vous rentrez dans l'histoire
parce que 20 ans après on en parle
encore il pèse chaque mot j'imagine dans
ce type de déclaration
comment vous avez préparé ce discours y
compris j'imagine avec Jacques Chirac
est-ce que ça a été rapide parce que
c'est pas le premier discours que vous
aviez prononcé sur le sujet en accord
avec le chef de l'État celui-là
précisément
il se dit que c'est vous qui dit un
moment on s'en manque de souffle ce
discours il va falloir nous mettre autre
chose il va nous mettre falloir nous
mettre la France vieux pays par exemple
donner de l'emphase à ce discours
c'était ça le la consigne donnait à
votre cabinet c'est vrai ce discours il
s'est fait en deux temps
la première partie vous vous aura
rappelez c'est l'argumentation et
l'objectif était pour ce qui concerne
extrêmement précis il s'agissait
véritablement de s'adresser aux
Américains à tous les États qui
voulaient partir en guerre pour leur
montrer à quel point cette cette
stratégie n'était pas la bonne donc il
s'agissait vraiment de choisir les
arguments sans blesser sans stigmatiser
mais vraiment pour montrer qu'en termes
de légitimité d'efficacité ce n'était
pas le bon chemin et puis très vite
cette partie argumentaire qui que j'ai
rodé pendant 6 mois dans les débats aux
Nations Unies sur les plateaux dans mes
rencontres donc c'est véritablement
comment arriver à à la réduction la plus
efficace dans un discours mais très vite
dans les dans les jours qui ont précédé
je me suis rendu compte que ça ne
suffisait pas et
j'ai pensé que pour être efficace pour
être le plus convaincant possible il
fallait signer ce discours il
m'appartenait de prononcer ce discours
au nom de la France et
évidemment sous l'autorité de Jacques
Chirac et donc j'ai voulu le
personnaliser et c'est pour cela que la
veille je me suis mis au travail et que
j'ai rédigé la deuxième partie avec le
souci de montrer que nous parlions aussi
au peuple et c'est pour ça que j'évoque
le temple d'une conscience les Nations
Unies qui n'est pas seulement une
institution mais qui est véritablement
une conscience naissante qui doit
s'affirmer c'est pour cela que j'ai
situé l'importance de la mémoire qui
était la nôtre nous sommes oui un vieux
pays un vieux peuple et et cela nous
donnait des devoirs y compris celui de
reconnaissance vis-à-vis des États-Unis
et c'est là justement dans les heures
qui ont précédé quand je me retrouve
dans le Concorde à retravailler ce
passage
pour arriver à New York que je me pose
la question est-ce que je me fais
plaisir est-ce que je me mets trop en
avant et c'est pour ça que je ne sais
jusqu'à la fin de demander à mes
collaborateurs est-ce que je garde le
vieux pays parce que cette partie là
Jacques Chirac ne l'avait même pas lu et
donc je bien sûr d'un peine arrivé à
peine posé nous envoyerons le discours
réécrit à Jacques Chirac mais je veux
vérifier qu'à aucun moment ce discours
ne laisse place au bon plaisir aux
effets de manche je veux véritablement
que ce discours soit celui de la France
entièrement dédié à faire avancer la
paix et les objectifs qui étaient les
nôtres il a fait date ce discours
objectif réussi 20 ans après on peut
dire ça en octobre 2019 dans une
interview accordée à Paris Match vous
dites vous dites que la France a payé le
prix fort dans cette affaire quel était
le prix qui a payé la France
alors après cette prise de position tout
le monde serait après ce qui s'est passé
la formule du condira il se disant qu'il
fallait punir la France donc nous avons
mis été nous avons été mis au bon
pendant une période donnée c'est le
French machine c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle à l'époque la bastonnade
française le French bashing il a bien
sûr eu lieu dans le dans les hautes
sphères de l'administration américaine
et de quelques États mais il a eu lieu
aussi dans la rue où on cassait les
bouteilles de vin français les French
Frye c'était convertis
et on voulait leur changer leur
dénomination
donc il y avait véritablement un
sentiment que la France n'était pas un
pays dit une pas un pays respectable et
que ce pays était en plus peuplé de
l'Arche et et ça
c'est important de le redire aujourd'hui
20 ans après
nous n'avons jamais cédé à ces
accusations et nous n'avons jamais
renvoyé ces accusations à aucun moment
vous ne trouverez dans la bouche de
Jacques Chirac ou de moi-même une
quelconque parole plus haute que l'autre
vis-à-vis des États-Unis Jacques Chirac
était un ami les États-Unis elle est
restée j'étais un ami des États-Unis
j'ai travaillé aux États-Unis j'ai été
élevé aux États-Unis j'ai passé mon bac
aux États-Unis
néanmoins nous avons estimé que ce
combat devait être mené parce qu'il nous
dépassait et qu'il dépassait les
relations franco-américaines et ne
l'oublions pas cette crise ouvre
d'autres séquences où les leçons de
l'Irak n'ont pas été tirées
rappelons-nous ce qui s'est passé en
Libye rappelons-nous ce qui s'est passé
après dans d'autres régions du monde et
y compris au Sahel une intervention
militaire l'exemple de la Libye où nous
sommes là pour le coup en première ligne
mais
l'intervention militaire ne peut réussir
que si elle est légitime donc fondée par
la communauté internationale que si elle
est brève parce que par ces quelques
mois bien très vite eu des troupes
deviennent des troupes d'occupation donc
il y a un certain nombre de règles à
respecter et c'est sur ce principe que
nous avons voulu nous battre et vous
êtes battus un peu seul contre tous
parce que lorsqu'on regarde la teneur
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale
durant cette crise alors c'était pas du
Shark baching c'était pas du Villepin
machine mais il y avait beaucoup de
hostilités à cette position du côté des
Atlantis qu'on a dénommé à l'époque les
atlantistes et on les trouvait pas
d'ailleurs uniquement dans le camp de la
droite parlementaire il y en avait un
certain nombre comme Pierre Lelouch on
va pas citer tout tous les noms il y en
avait aussi d'ailleurs du côté du du
Parti socialiste seulement mais je tiens
un peu seul contre tous y compris vous
pouvez même à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'occasion de se débat non les
institutions la sphère médiatique mais
il y avait plusieurs paramètres il y
avait le paramètre des relations
américaines des relations
transatlantiques il y avait le paramètre
des intérêts quand je recevais le Medef
j'étais évidemment couvert de critiques
il y avait une autre dimension qui est
la dimension occidentale alors même que
Jacques Chirac on le sait bien
celui qui a été le fondateur du Musée du
Quai Branly moi je suis né en Afrique
j'ai grandi en Amérique latine j'ai
servi dans les pays du Sud profondément
donc attachés au sud à un moment où la
tentation en France suivant les
Américains c'est de se replier sur un
occidentalisme alors que nous pensons
nous que nous sommes au début une
nouvelle mondialisation 2001 c'est
l'entrée de la Chine à l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce la mondialisation
change de nature les pays émergents sont
en train peu à peu de se tailler la part
de gâteau dans la croissance de la
mondialisation nos pays au contraire
voient cette part de gâteau rétrécir il
faut donc travailler à un nouvel ordre
mondial une nouvelle gouvernance
internationale moi je ne cesserai dans
tous mes discours de l'époque de dire à
quel point ce travail sur les crises
doit accompagner une refondation de
l'ordre internationale ceci n'est
absolument pas compris et
malheureusement on le voit à travers la
guerre du crâne aujourd'hui n'est
toujours pas compris aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
on continue à ne voir la guerre du crâne
qu'à travers le prisme de l'Europe et de
l'Occident on méconnait la réalité d'un
monde qui dépassait de beaucoup les
clivage qui sont les nôtres et donc
cette sensibilité au monde se soucie du
monde c'est le combat que nous avons lu
voulu porter avec Jacques Chirac vous
diriez que l'histoire vous a donné
raison en quelque sorte oui mais
l'important pas d'avoir raison
l'important c'est d'être compris d'être
capable de transmettre son message et il
y a encore beaucoup de travail à faire
merci Dominique de Villepin d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc spécial autour
de ce documentaire nous avons vu
ensemble pour nous remémorer ce qui a
été cette crise irakienne en 2004 ce
mensonge en 2003 pardon ce mensonge de
l'histoire et vous en êtes le grand
témoin totalement impuni je le dis à
l'heure où certains voudraient régler
des comptes sur d'autres crises
totalement impunies vos réactions ça
sera que sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter bien entendu merci Selma Sally
qui comme à la coutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission puis moi je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
doc et ça sera bien sûr comme d'habitude
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]